hi hi everyone thanks for joining we're
coming from different hours all of us I
think Shweta is in India Vinod mesh to
mine media in California what tech is in
Boston and speakers in Israel so I don't
know who wins who's got the largest gap
maybe it's wrong
tightening yeah how many hours 20 min I
have a big time okay great so my first
question is that the last time we saw
each other I guess live was about three
or four weeks ago for some of you and I
was wondering if we could just go
quickly around the table yeah according
to my screen and everybody just tell me
how how things unfolded when you early
however the last week's bin and then
we'll go on to the questions about
research resilience so Shweta you start
yes well so assignments was going
fantastic and then this thing started
happening I guess in the beginning I was
looking at it more like I was you know
in this wait and watch mode I was
waiting to see how things would unfold
but then it all happened very very
quickly so suddenly we stopped going to
office and then you know a couple of
days later there was the
shelter-in-place thing and then a few
days after that the Indian government
announced that all the air spaces will
close down so basically within the day
we decided to leave and left so it was
really very very everything was very
very fast and yeah I mean I'm back here
now and we're doing everything remotely
so yeah that's about what I have to say
yeah so I unfortunately had to have to
leave earlier than planned was great but
yeah under the circumstances I had to
head back and I went back and went into
two weeks of isolation at home and by
the time that was over
everybody else was also directors does
at home so I guess everybody just joined
us in isolation so that's that's the
that's the way the situation is it is
good to be in sort of familiar familiar
place and trying to you know trying to
maintain routine life as much as as much
as possible and there'd under the
circumstances work from home and so
forth I'm kind of curious I'm going to
told you didn't mention it but how do
you eat dramatic question you know
getting supplies I mean what happens in
India we we have been in strict
quarantine we're not supposed to step
out of the house so since I you know got
from the airport back home which in
itself was a low probability event that
I was very grateful for but you know we
got back home my husband and I and we
haven't stepped out since so essentially
our neighbors and friends have been
helping us out you know they leave stuff
at our doorstep and send us a message or
ring the doorbell and that's how we've
been managing and by the way I have to
say that we really getting spoiled I
mean I could really get totally used to
this like you know you're sitting at
home this grocery is coming and cooked
food coming in sometime so it's really
that's how we eat
I think overeating might be the problem
in this case yes the delivery services
but I was actually getting pre
overloaded I guess that's probably a
phenomenon around the world now so some
of these things you don't get everything
that you ordered or or things are sort
of delayed for very long time and yeah
we've also been getting a lot of help
when we were in isolation from friends
and from family sort of to bring the
things that we could not get could not
get via delivery and again we tried to
do as much as possible to just
get everything delivered and only things
in a different way when that's
absolutely essential so I think you are
going by the geographical distance from
birth yeah hi yes I was supposed to
arrive at Berkeley about a week before
the workshop started so around me much
I'm staying to the end of mate so it's
very much looking forward to arriving
from Boston and then I later realized
that you know I have to have to cancel
the travel plans but I'm very happy with
how the workshop worked out and I think
most opposed to being with a kept up
with research over zoom and even
everything else in terms of food it was
interesting I started worrying about not
having toilet paper and then I started
worrying about not being able to buy
food and vegetables and then the last
crisis I had was not being with the
white chili sauce right then basically
how to use every single kitchen
appliance that we have at home so yeah
so my timing was very marginally better
than howtechs I was really looking
forward to come because I couldn't come
the first two months because I was still
teaching at home and then I made it just
exactly three weeks ago and that was
just enough to spend like two and a half
days in the Symonds building which I
very much enjoyed and then I was ordered
to stay home so I could have driven back
down but the place I'm staying at here
in Berkeley has the advantage that it's
up in the hill and so there's all the
hiking paths in Tilden Park and so
that's that's one of the few things that
is not yet banned and so I'm just I'm
just enjoying that from here I'll just
go back down whenever I want to go back
down so we decided to stay on at
Berkeley and I spent the last week
organizing the workshop organized in the
workshop these three amazing people
and and you know I really enjoyed the
fact that it was a half-day workshop I
was a little skeptical about it at the
beginning because it gave me time to
think reflect back on the talks to even
watch them again and and think about it
that was very it was very helpful
research is going as usual everything
happens on Zoom I don't really see a
difference although it one has to take
the effort to reach out a little bit
more and surf you know be so punctual
with respect to uh you know appointments
something that I could get used to ms
the heart for you I've actually grown up
significantly since my graduate student
takes personally baby to more more time
with my ten month old daughter who is
both very delightful and very
challenging at the same time my wife is
spending you know the month writing a
haiku a day so that's the plot this new
project that we started because of the
time we are spending together so it's a
it's good well you know as as as as
people were leaving you know two
two-and-a-half three weeks ago I was
sort of rushing to get in meetings with
them you know and people were leaving at
an increasing rate and then about a week
ago I you know I was thinking well a
whole week has gone down in this
lockdown and I've got absolutely nothing
done during the week and and since then
over the over the last week it seems
like I've been constantly on zone either
for the workshop or for research
meetings or for some administrative
meetings but it feels like this you know
my days are longer than they were when
when we used to go into work so I guess
I'm the last one
[Music]
throw away from wish really the story
throw away and I guess you have to be
good a good shot a it's for me it's very
unusual I travel a lot and this is not
just not traveling but it's sitting in
the same house so I find it somewhat
maddening hey I take a lot of walks I
think that's the only rescue and in
terms of food you know and it's like
this continuous debate it was the
beginning to go into the store for how
long and then do you stay outside of the
store and you touch the cup to clean the
credit card you disinfect your phone
this is my note my new shop which people
have kind of raised to a level which I
find it hard to believe is at the end
that important but who am I to say I
have been wrong all along about all this
hey so I'm doing my best so which brings
me to my next question and that is as I
admitted I about a month ago I was still
optimistic that all our programs were
going to be run as usual and just people
who were you know extremely worried or
anxious by nature would decide to leave
but I was dispelled big time actually I
think I've never I have no problem with
waiting that I was wrong and I
definitely was wrong on this one and in
any case at the time we had questions
about Simon's what do we do do we cancel
the whole program do we delay workshops
we cancel workshops so we shorten them
and I think we had a very lively
discussion with differing opinions and I
think they're all represented on the
screen at the end I you know think that
in my opinion we've reached the right
conclusion in the sense that we didn't
delay so people didn't have time to kind
of salt and just detach and they were
still in the mode that they were in the
program and we did run the workshops
there's right now the quantum workshop
last week the lattices albeit in a
different form so my second question is
really how do you how do you feel about
this adaptation
and you know any thoughts any things
that you would like to say about this
nature of having to kind of change your
mind and say okay let's do it
differently let's go at it and do it
anybody
maybe I can go first so I was sort of
the chair for the workshop that was just
about to happen this is the one way we
really weren't sure whether you know
it's going to happen physically at all
or in what form is going so far and I
also have to admit that I was at the
other stream of Shafi I was one of the
more cautious and pessimistic ones and
so I think was great that we had all
this discussion with the different
viewpoints and you know I think really
the picture came from Mike organizers
coming true and having this great idea
to have sort of this tree to tree and a
half hour workshop day spread over five
days so some other problems addresses
all the issues about maybe what the
people we were to concentrate time zone
issues and so so if you let them talk
about how they how they helped out there
how they came up this idea well I don't
think it was just us I think this idea
just arose in the discussions and it
worked out really really great so you
know we had this half hour
sorry half day per day workshop and like
we know it said one thing is that it
gives you a chance to sort of you know
soak in the talks and think more about
them
the other thing is that with different
time zones like I'm in India that's
about 12 hours away it still made it
possible for me to attain so you know I
was attending from 9:00 p.m. to 1:00
a.m. there abouts but it was still
something that was doable at least for a
week
so I think that it's really fantastic
that you know this happened like we did
it like this I'm really glad that we did
not cancel or you know postponed
indefinitely as you know we went through
many of these options many many times
and it wasn't clear what was the right
thing to do but then we went with this
gut feeling that let's just keep going
and you know let's just do our best
while while we
keep going right and I think that it
worked out pretty well
like the workshop went very well there
were lots of participants and it was
great great overall anybody else
there was a question aspect we have to
consider was one with the venue and then
there's also the availability of
speakers and well part of it is sort of
hard constraints make people travel many
people need to have different time zones
and so on I think another major issue is
whether people actually feel like
attending a workshop at the time yeah
that's right something that we weren't
really sure actually very happy about
research and science life going going on
even in this everything you know in our
in order to sort of maintain this
research routine as much as we can even
under the circumstances so in that
respect I think we also learned to keep
that work very well sort of built on
what what what what speaker said people
were so stoked about the program you
know and then and then the workshop and
then and I think we did a good thing to
sort of keep it going
although in a different format it really
doesn't matter David all very happy that
that it happened and they actually
pitched in as you know sort of session
chairs you know the community pitched
and as you know not just the organizers
you know people from from the broader
community they sort of held out with
various things I you know I have
including the attendance you know and
questions and so forth and that was
really it was really good to see how
that's going but I do feel that because
it was thinking about because people
everybody could participate in all hours
it wasn't like I am only coming on
Wednesdays when I talk has to be on
Wednesday and so forth the way that
things were organised were
topic-specific so the first day was a
homogeneous second day was obfuscation
and it was fun of course cryptanalysis
so maybe it's the first order and that
was great because you really got sort of
a rundown of a particular field and
people built on top of each other and
that was because they could participate
on every day and you asked them to do it
on Monday they did it on Monday and so
forth so that was that was positive
another thing I thought about the latus
group which maybe as possible which
might be true about quantum but we'll
hear from you guys in a minute is that
it's a very it feels like a very
cohesive group they're a lot of people
know each other and the young people are
postdocs and students with people that
maybe were in the program which meant
that they came together so there was it
wasn't like well no maybe there was a
way to kind of not exactly pressure but
kind of support each other and say okay
let's do it
and I think that was very useful and
this might have been in most semester
over very much this way it's a strong
group knows each other in the midst of a
lot of research is going on so it's very
life and therefore these workshops could
happen so right at the drop of a hat and
I guess what you said about the mood I
know there was this discussion about
mental health and people are rightly
depressed and it would take the time to
recover I don't know my feeling is that
that might more time goes that's more
true but that's my feeling
you know that's my own feeling and it
looks like at least right now in the
first two weeks people were still
energetic and then just on a personal
note i for me was so useful I actually
found out some new things to work on
just from looking at these talks
actually I want to add this little point
here that empirically I think what we
found was that even though everybody is
obviously disturbed by the situation but
people really looked at this as
something very positive you know they
they were seeking
a sense of normalcy from the fact that
this was still happening and the general
vibe that I got from everybody that was
participating was extremely positive
like everyone seemed really happy and a
bead that they were part of this so that
was really very rewarding for all of us
yesterday I think I was a world special
dancing in those speakers cause we
basically had to shuffle that talks
around the last minute and of the
mulberry were always very positive about
and you know and they all gave really
good talks and then that the comedy was
great too after the first stage we got
love emails from people say everything's
going well with little people tomorrow
and you know like we know automation and
while the community is stepping up to
help us our chat sessions manage
question as well how about the quantum
workshop going and the whole transition
in the quantum program you guys wanna
speak about
I yeah I I think it was it's good to
remember what the the context was just
just because these things really
happened there was a week which is for
me it's two week delay right here where
every single day was a new week or a new
month or you know it's cool there was it
was completely unclear what was going to
happen the next day and the next day the
previous day seems like a wholly
different that was gone and so in this
kind of context is really hard to make
plans as to a workshop there's so many
other things on your mind that it's
really hard to put energy into
organization of an events that's two
weeks down the line and this looks like
it's gonna be ten years and what what
what are you know for me one of the
things that made the difference is these
town hall meetings that that each
program organized that I thought were
very successful and we just brought
people together at first in-person at
the assignments when we could and then
and then pretty quickly online to ask
them all you guys feel where is everyone
are you interested in this workshop and
then last as as we know things we
already said the response was very
enthusiastic so there's a lot of people
working these programs where were very
important so there's on postdocs and
students who came as fellows and they're
there for the whole semester and for
them this is really it's it's a really
important time in their career and
they're really looking forward to these
talks and the interaction and the
response we got from them was extremely
enthusiastic they they wanted it to
happen and they said yes let's have
things online let's have this workshop
let's just you know make it work um so I
think after we did that then then it was
clear that that we should put the
workshop on and then okay then all the
questions about all the other guys
brought up about the difficulties with
time zones with speakers that took a lot
of effort so though for the quantum
workshop that's happening this week the
main organizer is Henry UN and and he's
we put lots of effort coordinating with
everyone shuttling speakers based on
time zones and well I don't know mesh
maybe you want to say something I could
say more about the workshop and maybe
yeah so we've we've already had three
days of the workshop and there's today's
the last day so I think it's been a
great success it's been
I would say it's it's it's well beyond
my expectations going going into it and
actually there were times when we were
thinking of a much briefer workshop and
as it turns out it's actually been you
know many speakers stepped up to the
plate and I think the organizers did a
great job getting everybody together so
it's actually been quite as a pretty
substantial workshop and and with with a
pretty large attendance and you know a
lot of excitement around it so I think
that's that's been a great success I
should say just for just but just for
perspective you know I I think it's been
it's been you know it's been a great
success but there are there are a few
things still about about the in-person
workshops that I that I miss and maybe
these are these are things that that
possibly could be addressed with a with
you know with more evolution of the zoom
or something but but you know there are
there's just the person-to-person
interactions and the coffee breaks and
small groups and you know this is
something that obviously we cannot
replace by you know so if you were just
doing a you know there's you know asking
the question well is this online format
now as a solution or is it you know is
it an alternative right I don't think we
are there yet but but but I think it's
been such a great success for where we
are and the circumstances we have been
in sorry it's gonna be my next question
but just commenting on what you said
it's like the other time is very
interesting cuz you're right like one
day was no we all should be inside
second day is we should only sit for
seats apart from each other
third day is only ten people the
audience fourth day okay shelter at home
and you seem to get used to it extremely
quickly cuz okay I guess if it's this
gradual the fact that it was not gradual
even though it's quick when it was it
was one
every day you get more water I agree
with the wish that the smaller groups
are better in person or not in person
and I notice it as a panelist I think I
have maybe a little bit of a different
feeling than someone I was watching
because I've participated in the zoo in
both ways I wanted to see what he feels
like and as a panelist there's this chat
on the side where people are asking
questions as somebody who knows the
answer is answering and even coming up
with ideas that's a very nice aspect
which I think are large numbers you know
would be hard to do quickly so I agree
with that absolutely was very nice India
in the workshop and I guess they're
doing in the quantum so you know in the
last workshop I was in the panel but
this week I'm at least when I start off
I'm on the other side of the you know I
like I sign in using using the general
public's link and down you know one
thing that it is a big difference you
know in the sense that you have to sort
of type in your questions on the one
hand that forces you to sort of think a
little bit more about what you're asking
on the other hand you know you you you
know for someone like someone like me I
ask lots of questions
I you know I ask fewer you know when I
have to type it in so it's it's a bit of
a mixed mixed bag
I think people said what works well and
are there any challenges so I guess I
mentioned one challenge is there's no
coffee breaks or you can submit a chat
with people and get some sense of
intimacy which is a part of I guess any
kind of social any kind of collaboration
any kind of social interaction
I don't think zone could ever yeah I
agree I think that I would go even
further than what to may said so it's
absolutely spot-on that you know the
coffee breaks not being there not being
able to run into people that's a big
downside even but even watching talks I
kind of like being in an auditorium with
people around
me having the speaker in front of me I
think that there's something very human
about this you know being physically
present and maybe I'll get more used to
it but I don't I don't like this whole
let's do everything virtual and I don't
think it's any substitute at all I mean
you know you meet people there's like a
bonding that happens and it's really not
the same in zoom in fact this one of the
things that some of us talked about that
you know let's at least ask people to
keep their videos on and you know some
folks did and I think that helps a
little bit but I still think that that's
a very big component that's missing from
but you know that's me I mean others
might feel differently I'm a very
people's person so I I really like
seeing my people in front of me but yeah
I thought that was a big - you you were
leading to the next question really
which is such a success why do we have
to ever be at the same but on the
success side I must say that I think
there are more participants in these
workshops and we've had before I think
we had over 360 participants from 33
countries in the latticework shop so we
can identify that that these are unique
people participating and apparently over
1,500 viewers on YouTube I don't know
exactly what's happening we don't have
the numbers yet for the quantum workshop
but it also seems to be way up there hi
Henry hello hello so Henry tell me how
is the quantum workshop going I know you
you are like putting all your energy
into it in a bit of the lead organizer
offer so can you tell us how is it going
I think it's going pretty well
you know the the actually much better
than I expected so overall pretty happy
about it I think you know the the format
of the medium has some challenges in
terms of you know I think some people
wish there's more socialization but you
know I think
but during the talks I think the
interactions are pretty good you know
maybe the schedule can you know in terms
of like how long the breaks are it could
have been worked out a little bit better
but overall I'm pretty happy with it
and you know an interesting question is
given that it seems at least for these
two workshops that we're broadening
participation how can we still maintain
the socialization and get this type of
audience to come so in the people really
express the fact that they don't want to
completely do away with in person but
there are some advantages and
particularly reaching a wider audience
so I think an interesting question would
be how to combine these formats
so when you usually do this you know you
know in usual times I can't the remote
participants ask questions can they kick
in the interacts III didn't think they
could but maybe I'm wrong yeah I don't
you know that makes a little I think
that makes a significant difference so
you know we heard from a few people at
least a few people that normally won't
have made it in person to the workshop
but they they participated remotely or
actively I noticed it at least in the
lattice workshop in the beginning it was
mostly the panelists were asking
questions you know it's exactly those
people who would think no they were
material first of all you realized they
don't know the material or these they
don't know all of it and some things you
think would be people would know
no they asked a clarifying question is
extremely helpful then you realize many
people need this and somehow on when you
have to do is remotely you do it and the
audience people don't do it as much I
mean I do but I think most people are
kind of shy away from it they figure out
eventually they'll understand I think
when you are not online you don't think
that you're going to eventually
understand if you're gonna miss it now
you might kind of detach so that's my
maybe even if you're in the audience in
your Foreman an organizer if something
looks unclear to you maybe you could
type it in you know out loud we've
noticed that MIT years ago when they
start having Piazza then a lot more
women were participating in the Q&A at
that time the thought was that they
don't feel comfortable speaking up in
class but they do feel comfortable doing
it online so that ties in a little bit
to decision ID we can definitely tell
that from the Q&A feature who is asking
questions on this in though during the
seminars they're often students were
asking a question some of them we know
and you realize they're not typically
the people who ask questions and not
suddenly they're asking many questions
and you see that the reason they're
doing it is because it's it's it's
easier you're not feeling intrusive and
you're not and then you get your answer
it is it's also nice that I think the
feature that I've all the panelists see
the answers and some of them can also
answer on behalf of the speaker maybe if
it's an easy answer or there can be a
little the site discussion about the
point that someone raises and that that
helps a little bit we create this this
community feeling where it can be a
discussion among everyone that's
actually better thing than a real life
seminar where you can't really speak up
or you can't really speak to your
neighbor I mean that's you can't but
that's rude
whereas now this is easy so you can have
a chat with other attendees well I mean
I was going on and I find that really
really useful keep engaging to talk to
so maybe this is actually you know I
completely agree with what Thomas said
and maybe this is a little bit of a
contrarian perspective but but I
actually enjoyed the workshop the
virtual workshop more than the real one
you know you know there was perhaps it's
a function of my being on the panel you
know there was so much discussion among
the panelists that I frankly don't think
that level of discussion would have
happened you know to that extent you
know in a real workshop maybe I'm
missing something but I really enjoyed
well it could be that in fact you could
have that even if you're sitting in the
audience because you're sitting on the
audience I can ask somebody was sitting
next to me what do they mean what is X
you know I can't ask it but if we had
the format that we could type while
we're sitting in the room in lieu of
speaking up it would be seems to have
been useful here we also you have to
understand about the totally remote
versus I mean something in you know in
place is that if we didn't have those
two months at Berkeley and the Institute
I don't think this would have happened
it was having these connections and
knowing each other and kind of having
the seminars and bantering and and and
kind of knowing what the personalities
are that allowed this very free exchange
of ideas I don't think this will happen
if we we didn't have that feeling among
us maybe we should have the program in
person in the workshops everyone goes
there to their homeland but I I'm
confident a hundred percent that this
was taking place it wasn't this cord of
people who either know each other from
before or actually we're in the place
and if debated these topics in the town
halls like like anybody standing there
and kind of shouting their opinion you
just felt like you know a community and
do it by the word by the word okay
another thing I wanted to ask sort of
moving away from our particular
workshops in this experiment is
obviously this is a tragedy and uh you
know scale that we have a known
experience even my son was asking Mises
so you've never seen anything like this
to him I'm like that woman on the hill
said no not me not my my but in any case
it is also affected our community and
other aspects our own computer science
community and the kind of things that
I'm thinking of is you know school's out
I mean it's remote but a lot of people
are kind of were using this time
grades are not gonna get great pass/fail
that's the least of one's trouble but I
know some people some students are
troubled by their in terms of the jobs
that are gonna be available for seniors
and postdocs I think's a little bit it's
not as good as it was because we don't
know essentially what's gonna happen
financially there's higher increases
there have been announced certain
universities I think the first one was
Stanford
there's projected economic shutdowns
there's health concerns for the future
people don't know what the outcome is so
what do you think about research do you
see any challenges that are posed by
this or maybe opportunities I mean there
are some new research questions have
come up especially for the theory
community so I was wondering anything
that you want to say about this oh you
know I haven't seen any difference in
research for myself but I'm a little
worried about sort of young people you
know because sort of you know if you're
a beginning graduate student you know
lot of research is to actually cultivate
research relationships you have to meet
people how do you meet people you go to
seminars you go to work right and you
know I was talking to a student of mine
yesterday and Lisa and she told me you
know you know III had this schedule
before that she would wake up you know
one o'clock and they have to know you
know and then she would sort of go to
MIT and when she walked into him IT a
switch turned on and she wasn't research
more than you go walk to walk get a cup
of coffee or tea you meet people then
you you know you get into the mode I
think part of it was actually also sort
of seeing your collaborators and your
fellow students and that's missing and
I'm you know again I'm not worried about
me and worried about the younger
generation of people especially the
beginning I guess yeah I mean because
part of you know a large part of my you
know grad school was actually hanging
out with friends and uh you know in very
informal settings and and research would
come up you know you know because that's
what we were all thinking about and
that's all research happened and
somehow I'm a little worried that that's
you know that's not happening it's not
going interesting anybody else I guess
one thing I've tried to do in the last
couple of weeks is to have like a zoom
hangout for you know my students and and
you know people who are working with me
just to create some continuation of that
social atmosphere and it's like half of
it is just chatting and and half of it
is you know someone's giving some it's
like a half of a reading group or
something like that just to keep some
science but also some socialization and
I think that it seems like people have
been enjoying that of course it's no
substitute for like being in person but
it's just some kind of maybe half
measure to try to make up for the loss
it's a very good idea I've done it with
some students some subset and
interestingly in contrast with what the
note said some of them say well this is
how I live all the time what's different
I had one student who said this that I
did the same as Henry we were having
this lunch together in front of the
computers and and he said well you know
this is great I can finally be myself of
which is this introverted person who
likes to work from home and have quiet
days so he seemed pretty happy about I
mean generally it's true that it's
challenging to switch from you know
being at home mode to work mode for the
students who live in not such big places
and so they don't have a room that's an
office and so a lot of them we're
getting creative solutions they're
moving their desks you know they live
usually they share they often share
house and so they're putting their desks
that next to each other and creating a
workspace where they can no go there and
be next to each other and feel that it's
a bit like being in the in the office
you know I I have to say that my
experience of this has been you know I
used to be very resistant to using
collaborating on you know online resume
or or Skype or something because I found
it very hard to you know the fact that
you can't write and so on you know
draw stuff and and now that I've done it
I find it they actually I find it
extremely you know it's it's a it's a
good way of collaborating it's it allows
you to focus and if you have a tablet
you can you can even write and sketch
and and you know my general feeling
about about this period is that it's
it's evolutionary pressure you know that
that it's a it's something that's come
up and it's it's making us all evolve I
feel like I'm going from being a being a
dinosaur in this in this respect to the
next and and and I feel that this is
true in in in dimensions you know like
as a community we could be resisted you
know online online instruction and
teaching and I think that those barriers
are going to come down dramatically and
I think you know my I'm a bit of an
optimist so I feel that this is this is
going to pass in a few months but what
its going to leave in its wake is is a
lot of new you know and and more
efficient ways of doing things and more
effective ways of doing things you know
both both in terms of research because
because you know the more we collaborate
you know widely you know without without
geographical constraints the more it
democratizes research and I think that's
a great thing and then in terms of
teaching I think it's you know online
tools are are going to help us focus
more on what learning and teaching is
about as opposed to the repetitive
aspects of it I actually view this as
well as you know positive thing oh yeah
because I need to take care of someone
who's once attention 24/7 and then also
focus means you have to compromise I
mean anyway you have to do that when you
who's taking care right but that's
that's tough so I think that's that's
true
people are there are a lot of people who
invade difficult situations a lot of
people both in our community in general
are facing difficulties that are not
related to research life related to you
know actual living life in terms of job
concerns children health of course
family members and so on and I think a
part of sort of part of our are dealing
with the situation is to actually
instead of being aware that people are
going to be concerned people are going
to be distracted and I think we need
those through enable that to that extent
and be minded it to the situation and
not sort of context so we're trying a
lot of things to sort of keep research
going and this is I think this is good
and this is giving support I think this
is sort of emotionally supporting a lot
of us I think sort of being able to do
what we think we know how to do but but
again we have to sort of keep in mind
that it's not always possible and sort
of give people who have more hardship
also sort of way to deal with it without
without being feeling that they should
be you know working on research even
when they can but I think this is doing
it and it's interesting what you brought
up seeker that this human part even
though we're doing it remotely
but you always sort of see the
circumstances that people are in you
know maybe a child go by or and you are
since you're in the same situation
you're also locked at home you're more I
feel more apathetic to it's like okay
and as people see more I'm willing to
accept the fact that somebody may have a
different pace than you do it might take
them more time that's the sense that I
get rather than just judging someone by
a Productivity or an idea the degree you
know there's more context to how that
emerges which is bring some more
patience I hope I was just going to say
we're another side of this is that we're
getting to know
colleagues in sort of more intimate ways
than we're used to so when we're having
these faculty meetings where typically
everyone is in the same room and dressed
in the suits now on people are in their
garage or in their kids bedroom or
hugging a cat on the couch and it's a
very different atmosphere and I think a
positive way because it's a little bit
you know it's humanists what Jeffrey was
saying it's it's getting to know and
respecting everyone's are constraints
and the life that they're having yeah
that's that's actually exactly what I
was going to say that I think this kind
of a situation it brings us closer
because you know there is you cannot
sort of ignore the personal life you
cannot separate it completely from the
professional life anymore and now when
we talk to people you know it's very
natural to find out how their families
are doing who's in their family where
they live what's going on you know did
they eat what did they stuff like that
so I think that it's definitely brought
a sense of closeness within the
community and this is something that
perhaps every crisis does it's one of
the upsides of a difficult time like
this absolutely
so I guess there is that part of my
question was there are some research
questions that come up maybe this is not
the right format because we're talking
about resilience in this interview but
there's definitely I know in the
cryptography side there's questions
about contact tracing you know where
does Liberty when we talk about privacy
we're always talking about you it's sort
of clear where the bad guys are people
trying to take our privacy away but now
you know the issues are really health
life-and-death versus privacy it's a
much more delicate situation and maybe
more fundamental so we have to
understand where are the privacy
concerns come in and
utility maybe is reduced or maybe you
can get both and that's what we are
hoping and so we've been advocating for
a long time and the question is whether
in this situation that's really true and
how to do it efficiently there's lots of
other questions it's very computer
science I know sort of computational
epidemiology is a field there are very
interesting questions even even small
questions you know how do you make sure
that everybody can walk six feet apart
when they leave the house it's an
unsolved question certainly algorithmic
question anybody else with questions
that have come up I mean there's tons
that I have but I'm not gonna listen
well a colleague from India wrote to me
because he's trying to get get them to
do pooling for tests you know instead of
doing tests for covert 19 one at a time
you you take many people's samples
together and do one test so you deal
with the fact that you know with the
scarcity of tests and so there are there
were questions there about well how do
you do this when you know
well first he had questions about what's
the best algorithm and then I could
point him to the literature but then
there were questions about though his
tests are not very reliable and then
what can you do with that and so on so
so it was it's we are actually as you
served a lot of interesting questions
that come out of one can actually
potentially make a difference invites
what I think it's like a right there was
a faculty meeting where like eight
faculty came up and talked about what
they're doing there's connected with
voters
[Music]
your science in math and also of course
in other departments that are really
sort of harnessing all the sort of tools
and knowledge that they have towards
this whether it is in so we heard from
people from the chemistry department I'm
trying to confine molecules that inhibit
the reproduction of viruses and
from biology who are helping to conduct
tests at higher volume than was possible
before and people in our departments in
various various aspects some like you
said in trying to sort of large amounts
of data and sort of try to analyze it in
order to sort of predict trends using
statistical tools combined with with
computational biology tools in order to
sort of predict trends before they
appear on the surface there's issues of
privacy that are being that are being
addressed by by people at Weitzman
in fairness of course trying to sort of
use tools like fairness in order to sort
of derive insights about this virus
based on information that we have about
other types of sicknesses yeah and a lot
of signal processing in order to try to
get better imaging and in radiology to
do that more efficient and more
streamlined hope I'm not forgetting yeah
so really trying to apply a variety of
tools and and try to sort of help in
various aspects of this situation so I
think in many cases people discovered
that this these things that they were
thinking about in the context of their
research all of a sudden can be useful
also to benefit humanity and I think
this is also something that's really
encouraging to see that that you know
this this thing that we are part of
academia and science in general you know
of course the contribution of science in
humanity is something that is not I
think in dispute but even the situation
people can sort of shift really quickly
from working on theory or things are
more abstract to applying it to this
specific situation
yeah so so I think a lot of people in
vitamin RR are sort of harnessing their
great I guess we're almost done with the
hour I think it is actually an hour I
just wanted to say sort of on there
there we're trying to keep up social
events up assignments like a nice
surprisingly the students are organizing
game nights where they do these online
games with all the participating
I haven't participated that yet on the
other hand I don't also participate in
the real life game like and this daily
tea I haven't been to one of them how is
that going anybody yeah I think I've
been a few times I think they've been
nice so it's a small number of people
coming but it's seven eight people
chatting you know on the couch for half
an hour and all we've been using it to
update each other on who's playing back
on what they and how things are at home
and the kind of things that I think
they're nice so they they continue a
little bit informal interactions that
that we had that assignments a little
bit challenge because everyone's day now
is different and it's not the cookies to
attract people but I think that for some
fraction of the participants it's it's a
valuable thing to have because because
they really the program at assignments
is an important part of their quarter
and if that program ends then it it
feels very lonely and so it's I think
they're they're nice they've been
working out nicely just as a social
social things
we have to make sure that none of the
workshops are going to be over I mean
they're going to be to our workshops
that we still have something that
happens during the week that has some
kind of punch to it you know that people
want to join
we had a woman's just as an ending
we had a woman's party where all the
women for both programs and lettuces and
and quantum participated I thought was a
great it was a great meeting definitely
it was really nice I talked about
themselves and some shared something
about their themselves in general not
just related to the coronavirus so with
this sense of community I want to thank
everyone for what you've done and and
let's keep going and on one more note of
optimism we are definitely going to run
a program for both the lattices and the
quantum and hopefully at the same time
in the future to make up for those two
months that we've missed out so in my
mind it would be great if it happened
next summer and to the extent that
people can come that they would spend
some significant amount of time at
Berkeley and we will definitely support
it on the Symons side and then we could
actually be in the same room and have
cookies bye everyone